[Musique]
c'est l'heure du journal de l'afrique
seraient les bienvenues sur france 24 à
la une ce soir un ancien chef de la
milice janjawid devant la cour pénale
internationale de la haye et il est
accusé de crimes de guerre et de crimes
contre l'humanité il a plaidé non
coupable il s'agit du premier procès sur
les crimes au darfour cette région de
l'ouest du soudan théâtre d'un vincent
il y a près de 20 ans
ce nouveau rapport glaçant de human
rights watch ong dénoncent des exactions
commises par les forces armées maliennes
dans le village de moura dans le centre
du pays une localité qui a fait l'objet
d'une vaste opération militaire entre le
23 et le 31 mars l efama avait indiqué
avoir tué deux sans trois jihadistes
nous serons avec karine caniza natalia
de l'eau angie human rights watch
et à la fin de ce journal nous
écouterons les populations qui ont fui
leurs villages dans l'est de la
république démocratique du congo un
exode après de violents combats entre
l'armée congolaise et le m23 les
villageois sont sommés à présent de
rentrer chez eux mais ils refusent par
peur de la reprise des combats
ce premier procès sur les crimes au
darfour un ancien chef de la milice
janjawid forces supplétives du
gouvernement soudanais a plaidé non
coupable mardi de crimes de guerre et de
crimes contre l'humanité lors de
l'ouverture de son procès devant la cpi
la cour pénale internationale
un procès pour des atrocités commises au
darfour théâtre d'un 25 il ya près de 20
ans
la correspondance à l'oeil de stéphanie
maupas
le procureur dit que c'est une des lunes
utilité de ce procès s'était il rappelé
ces crimes que beaucoup de gens ont
oublié alors il a détaillé les crimes
qu'il reproche à ali kushayb à l'accusé
vous savez c'était un chef djandjawid un
ces milices qui semait la terreur dans
les villages du darfour il a détaillé il
a évoqué beaucoup de témoignages assez
poignant au cours de cette journée et
puis dans un second temps il a aussi
évoqué le rôle de la communauté
internationale dans ce procès parce que
vous vous rappelez en 2005 le conseil de
sécurité des nations unies
v saisie la cour pénale des crimes
commis au darfour puisque le soudan n'a
pas ratifié le traité de la cour donc il
fallait une action du conseil de
sécurité et cette action elle a bien eu
lieu et le procureur a d'ailleurs
souligné qu'à l'époque et bien même la
russie avait avait voté en faveur d'une
telle résolution votée en faveur de la
justice et puis dans un troisième temps
de ceux de ses déclarations aujourd'hui
le procureur a aussi évoqué la situation
des survivants aujourd'hui ceux qui sont
encore dans des camps de réfugiés au
tchad ceux qui sont dans des camps
déplacées à l'intérieur du darfour ou
ceux encore qui sont exilés et qui
souffre encore de traumatismes depuis
depuis cette guerre du darfour même si
vingt ans presque vingt ans ont passé
depuis voilà c'était les audiences
d'aujourd'hui alors demain ça sera les
avocats des victimes qui vont qui vont
s'exprimer un court instant un pur pour
expliquer un peu ce qu'ils attendent de
ce procès et puis ensuite l'accusé
devrait prendre la parole pour quelques
minutes et enfin il ya le procureur
pourra appeler à la barre son premier
témoin on attend un expert de la
situation au darfour
on commence on en vient pardon à ce
rapport de human rights watch un rapport
aux poings tendus de nouveau du doigt
les femmes allaient forcer armée à
malienne l' ong les accuse de massacre
dans le village de moura dans le centre
du pays c'est dans cette localité que
l'armée malienne avait lancé une
opération du 23 au 31 mars contre des
djihadistes les femmes affirment avoir
tué deux sans trois combattants
islamistes un bilan contesté par les ong
karine caniza natalia directrice du
plaidoyer pour l'afrique pour human
rights watch est notre invité merci
d'être avec nous tout d'abord comment
avez vous procédé pour réaliser cette
enquête et sortir ce rapport
merci d'abord je vous remercie de nous
inviter
tu maintenant et swatch a parlé avec
nous avons parlé à une vingtaine de
villageois présents lors de l'incident
en question y compris ceux de la ville
de moura comme vous l'avait dit et des
villageois qui se sont rendus à mucha
pour assister au marché un marché qui se
tient
généralement de façon hebdomadaire donc
nos enquêteurs se sont entretenus avec
ces villageois ceux qui sont qui étaient
eux qui sont mieux marcher avec des
experts en sécurité des dirigeants
communautaires et d'autres personnes par
téléphone et aussi en personne nous
disposons il faut dire que nous
disposons d'un vaste réseau de personnes
qui fournissent des qui nous fournissent
des informations sur les violations des
droits commises par par toutes les
parties y compris les islamistes armés
les groupes d'autodéfense sont appelés
non
langage courant les milices et les
forces de sécurité
et en effet il faut dire qu'il ya de
nombreux témoins qui ont été victimes
des deux camps alors que conforte les
témoignages
et bien les témoin que nous à qui nous
avons parlé nous ont décrit comment des
soldats maliens et étrangers ont mené
une vaste opération on se retrouve à
moura qui est sous le contrôle des
djihadistes il faut le dire mourat qui
est sous contrôle des djihadistes depuis
plusieurs années après un échange de
coups de feu avec un groupe d'environ 30
jedi djihadistes près du marché en
question les soldats qui sont arrivés en
hélicoptère ont donc les la ville et
arrêté presque tous tous les hommes
adultes des centaines d'entre eux y ait
encore des habitants de moura et de
nombreux commerçants en provenance
d'autres villages et après les avoir
amenés dans un dans un endroit à l'est
de la ville les détenus ont été emmenés
pendant plusieurs jours par petits
groupes et exécutés par des soldats
maliens et blanc quelques témoins ont
dit évidemment aussi nous ont dit que
dès que des détenus avaient été obligés
de creuser quelques certaines un certain
nombre de fosses communes dans
lesquelles de nombreux morts de nombreux
corps plutôt ont été mis les survivants
décrivent ont décrit des jours des
moments de peur et de terreur effroyable
en voyant leurs amis leurs parents et
outre et autres personnes exécutées
alors d'après d'après votre rapport le
bilan avancé par les femmes à qui
affirme avoir tué 203 jihadi serait bien
plus lourd et des témoignages affirment
également que des civils ont été ciblés
en fonction de leur appartenance
ethnique notamment les peuls
oui il faut dire qu'il ya une dynamique
ethnique clair dans le conflit 1 au
sahel les jihadistes ont taxé axent leur
recrutement sur les peules les foulani
en exploitant leurs griefs à l'égard du
gouvernement et des autres et d'autres
groupes ethniques et tous les témoins 1
ce que nous avons parlé s'accordent à
dire que l'ethnie paul qui est de toute
façon largement qui est aussi largement
il faut le dire majoritaire dans cette
région a été particulièrement ciblés en
effet une semble nous semble qu'il
s'agit évidemment il s'agit d'un crime
de guerre et mais aussi qui traduit un
exemple de punition collective contre
des civils poehl pour leur soutien réel
ou supposé un aux islamistes armés et il
faut dire que le mois de mars a été un
mois brutale et meurtrier pour les
civils notre organisation et human
rights watch investit d'ailleurs
également conduit des enquêtes en ce
moment et rendra compte prochainement de
d'un certain de centaines de civils qui
ont été tués justement par la filiale de
l'état islamique à ménaka au mali et
dans les environs alors j'aimerais quand
même le soulever sa voie là alors
justement dans le précédent rapport vous
disiez que rythme annuel soit en tout
cas et témoignages sur lequel se basent
erima soit je parlais d'hommes blancs
comme vous venez de l'évoquer
accompagnant les femmes à les forces
armées maliennes des hommes qui ne
parlait pas français il supposer qu'il
s'agissait de mercenaires du groupe
privé russe wagner avez vous plus
d'éléments allant dans ce sens
aujourd'hui
depuis l'année depuis le début de
l'année 2022 je me noie et swatch a
documenté la présence de soldats blancs
non francophones dans plusieurs
opérations pour desquelles des abus ont
été perpétrés
y compris il ya quelques semaines le
meurtre de 35 hommes qui avaient été
détenus dans le camp militaire de diaba
lidge a les témoins les décrivent
alternativement comme des soldats blancs
ou des russes et des russes et le disent
parce que lorsque le gouvernement
rappelez-vous a reconnu en décembre 2021
la présence de formateurs russe mali
notons toutefois donc là c'est ce qu'on
peut dire nous notons évidemment que la
queue que la communauté internationale
ait compris gouvernement des états unis
l'union européenne la france etc
ont confirmé depuis quelque temps la
présence d'un groupe du groupe ou hagner
mais notre mais nos témoins autre témoin
ceux à qui nous parlons largement
décrivent des hommes blancs
et parfois ils disent que ce sont des
russes mais ce qu'il faut dire c'est que
quel qu'il soit un peu importe leur
nationalité
il est de la responsabilité du
gouvernement de transition malien de
l'est continue et de s'assurer qu'ils
respectent les droits et de veiller à ce
que tous les militaires maliens ou
étrangers impliqués dans des allégations
d'exactions rendent des comptes et soit
tenu comme responsable
et enfin nous demandons instamment
malien de mener eux mêmes des enquêtes
crédibles afin de permettre à la
minustah et à l'union africaine
notamment de pouvoir enquêter sur ces
allégations qui sont très inquiétantes
et plus largement nous demandons aux uns
ou maliens gouvernement transition
malien de veiller à ce que les
opérations de contre-terrorisme respecte
les droits et nous et il faut que je il
faut le dire à la face et que nous le
disons pour pour deux raisons
principalement la première raison c'est
une raison de principe c'est contraire
au droit national au droit international
humanitaire d'exécuter des personnes non
armées et civils mais aussi il ya des
raisons pratiques qui nous pousse à
faire cette recommandation c'est que de
plus en plus
ces abus ne font que favoriser le
recrutement
dans des groupes ethniques des ennemis
qui finissent par tuer de plus en plus
de civils comme cela était le cas
d'ailleurs en mars à ménaka aidant les
forces de sécurité maliennes je rappelle
encore une fois que je m'adresse moi je
vais publier un rapport sur la situation
et à ménaka et merci et nous en
parlerons d'un journal de l'afrique
merci beaucoup karine incana n'a tout
lié à directrice du plaidoyer pour
l'afrique pour human rights watch merci
pour ce décryptage complet on en vient
un autre rapport celui de l'institut
pour l'économie et la paix basé à sydney
un rapport annuel sur l'évolution du
terrorisme mondial en 2021 et dans ce
global terrorisme index le niger occupe
la deuxième place dans le classement du
nombre de morts liées au terrorisme
entre 2020 et 2021 les détails avec
notre correspondant à niamey harold
girard
ce sont de nouvelles données qui
viennent confirmer ce qui est ressenti
ici depuis l'année dernière le
territoire nigérien est de plus en plus
dangereux selon l'institut pour
l'économie et pour la paix les morts
dues aux violences terroristes auraient
augmenté entre 2020 et 2021 au niger de
129% selon l'étude le nombre de victimes
auraient donc plus que doublé passant de
257 personnes en 2020 à 588 en 2021 la
région la plus touchée c'est celle de
tillabéri où les attentats se
multiplient contre civil et militaire
depuis plus de deux mois maintenant pour
beaucoup la situation à laquelle fait
face cette région nigérienne de
tillabéri est une conséquence directe de
l'instabilité dans le mali voisin depuis
le début c'est un conflit qui a quitté
le mali pour se répandre ce n'est les
pays frontaliers comme le niger et le
burkina et qui aujourd'hui c'est encore
le bénin donc du coup plus le conflit
s'intensifie
omani plus les répercussions vont aller
sur les vols est ce que les villes les
villages frontaliers de ce pays une
instabilité qui impose une pression
sécuritaire au niger mais aussi
migratoires le haut commissariat aux
réfugiés relève qu'en trois semaines au
mois de mars c'est au moins 18000
personnes qui fuyant les violences au
mali sont arrivés au niger
que les militaires et les policiers nous
précède c'est la réponse des populations
qui ont fui leurs villages dans l'est de
la république démocratique du congo les
autorités les sommes de regagner leurs
maisons mais après les violents combats
entre l'armée et les rebelles du m23 en
début de semaine dernière et ils sont
convaincus que les affrontements vont
reprendre leur ambert stecher
patience ni ondimba était à l'hôpital
lorsque les premiers coups de feu ont
retenti
enceinte de neuf mois la jeune femme dû
s'enfuir avec le personnel hospitalier
sans savoir si son enfant allait sur
vire
nous avons tous fui patients médecins
infirmières
personne n'est resté dans l'hôpital
c'est un jour que je n'oublierai jamais
un homme m'a conseillé de rester à
l'hôpital parce que je n'allais pas
survivre mais j'ai tenu bon goût
ratatouille patience a finalement
accouché d'un petit garçon à l'hôpital
de route chaud c'est ici dans cette
ville proche de la frontière ougandaise
que des milliers de rescapés fuyant les
violences dans le nord kivu affluent
depuis la semaine dernière sans réelle
structure d'accueil ils s'entassent dans
des écoles et des églises où ils dorment
à même le sol
débordés les autorités locales leur
demande de regagner leurs villages mais
ces derniers ont peur que les combats
reprennent malgré les assurances des
forces de sécurité déployées à lucho
laissez moi vous dire que nous allons
laisser les bureaux à kinshasa pour
venir mourir ici puisque cette partie
ses pattes ailées territoire national
la semaine dernière le m23 avaient
attaqué et pris le contrôle de plusieurs
villages à l'est de la rdc avant de se
retrancher dans les collines
avoisinantes
l'ancien groupe de rebelles tutsis
avaient repris les armes en novembre
dernier en accusant le gouvernement
d'avoir violé un accord de paix datant
de 2013
voilà c'est la fin du journal de
l'afrique rester avec nous dans quelques
instants la suite de paris direct avec
audrey racines
[Musique]
au cameroun les violences contre les
personnes lgbt ne cesse d'augmenter
elles sont documentés par nos
observateurs qui tentent de les prévenir
de secourir les victimes mais également
de sensibiliser la société dans cet
épisode de ligne directe nous partons à
leur rencontre au plus près de ce
phénomène et les observateurs ligne
directe présentée par corentin baigner à
voir sur france 24 et france 24 points
comme contre la transmission pensons
aération
quand on parle quand on rit et même
quand on respire des microgouttelettes
invisibles à l'oeil nu restent en
suspension dans l'air et peuvent
transmettre le virus du comique 19 c'est
pourquoi il est important d'aérer 10
minutes toutes les heures pour les faire
disparaître
même vacciné continuons à appliquer les
gestes barrière
ceci est un message du ministère chargé
de la santé et de santé publique france